hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to another SpongeBob
horror game this one called Sinister
Squidward people say that this might be
the best ones so far
I will be the judge of that I'm a bit of
a connoisseur when it comes to SpongeBob
horror games
[Music]
my name is Squidward and I hate my life
I wake up every day go to work and come
back home
nothing ever changes I'm thinking of
killing myself
before I kill myself I want to kill the
people I hate
oh I can't stand working here everyone
is so fat and annoying I don't care
anymore I'm going to kill all these
people
I love the voice I'm ready to die oh my
God this looks too good for what it is
all right but no the children dancing
they're having such a good time how
could I oh well hmm
well
part of the game
ah this feels bad
I
you're dead now
burning hell you bastards wow
there you go sorry dude
huh it's time I kill Mr Krabs
oh
[Music]
Mr Crap
I don't know about this one it's not as
much of a horror game as I thought it's
just it's locked where is the key
where is the key
where could the key be
this is way too intense
there's so much more than I thought it
would be ah there it is perfect
as jokes on you you left the key outside
Mr Krabs
where did he go
Mr Krabs he's in the walls
he's in the goddamn walls okay
what is happening here is that a gun I
came to kill you
and I'll take your money
no
see you inhale
oh
sorry oh he's already dead what did I do
that I did that already he's dead I
don't remember did I did I
I did I did it I killed Mr Krabs it was
me all along
[Music]
foreign
breaking news a mass shooting happened
today on Krusty Krabs the perpetrator
Squidward Tentacles has somehow managed
to escape law enforcement and has
kidnapped his neighbor's SpongeBob and
Patrick the Bikini Bottom Police have
reported that he is currently holding
the two of them hostage and has
threatened to kill them if they tried to
intervene in other news John buckett has
reported an increase in sales since the
incident
oh I cannot believe Squidward did
something this bad I should go find
SpongeBob and Patrick and help him I
hope I don't have to kill Squidward
what what is happening
oh no okay now
now the horror game begins
ah I see
SpongeBob
why
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
all right well ah didn't expect you to
are you always just right there
you always right there or yeah you're
you're right there which is
really unpleasant for me why would you
be right there
[Music]
okay well don't go down that way ever
forever and ever
oh horrible
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no it was horrible
okay
um
oh well then can I hide in here oh I
can't yes
oh no
does that mean he's is he going away
he's going away
okay so if he went that way
then that means this way might be
nevermind
I can't assume that is AI is going to be
too smart this is Squidward we're
talking about living room well that's
nice
what am I looking for by the way
uh
I see okay I think I heard him coming
down this way
oh yeah oh yeah um okay well if that's
there then
should be able to go around at least I
could always leave I guess but that
wouldn't be very Sandy right Sandy would
stick up for her friends I suppose
oh interesting hmm
I you know I don't know why but I didn't
think this game would be quite this deep
but apparently it is
got a crowbar there's some kind of
combination lock
upstairs there
so I can open
something with this
he's going away
I was wondering if that would be able to
draw him in
okay there were boards
okay
uh
[Music]
where are you going
okay he's gonna go in there
he went back that way before I don't
know if he's going to come down this way
okay good
okay
[Music]
I'm in oh no Patrick you're not tied
down in any way you could literally move
all right
oh here we go nope never mind
um
oh
[Music]
I don't know if there's anything in here
that can like help me unlock the
padlock at the front to turn off the
power maybe that would do it gotta be
some form of a code somewhere in here
so we can find a code to the combination
lock maybe that'll give me what I need
I'm guessing huh
oh of course I have a promo
finally I'm free I got circumcised again
oh hey all right guys he's not gonna
chase me or anything like that oh yeah
Patrick don't worry I got you buddy
press e to talk Sandy thank you for
saving me you're welcome let's get you
out of here okay let's go and one more
thing Patrick if you see SpongeBob
I think I did Squidward took him to the
living room okay
lead Patrick to the exit ah
about that how slow are you gonna go
that slow
look I'm not even sneaking I don't know
why you think you need to
all right Coast might be clear
I have no idea if the coast is clear
Patrick Patrick do you see anything down
at the end of this hallway
Patrick could you be any slower Patrick
this is truly terrible
I get it that you're bleeding from the
crotch but this is uh this is not
helpful
Patrick hurry up Patrick
hat Rick
my God please do not get stuck in the
door
uh
Patrick please Patrick please just get
outside
please I guess he's not here he might
have moved on go Patrick please leave
thank you
foreign
wow I actually saved him that seems hard
to believe anyway living room I know
where the living room is
live
well you know late later later I'll look
at it later
how are you just gonna keep chasing me
it's probably fine living room
doesn't seem to be anything in the
living room
[Music]
oh wait is this move does this button
move this
ah there we go
ah why does SpongeBob have this like
Secret
passageway
is this Squidward's house or is it
SpongeBob's house because there's a lot
of
[Music]
okay I've made it upstairs
and for what
ah oh
can I have that I guess I don't want
that because Sandy for some reason
doesn't want to kill us good word
a pacifist right that's what
I just want to leave oh
[Music]
oh no Gary no no no
ah it's so sad uh SpongeBob SpongeBob
where are you
SpongeBob
oh
oh hi uh are you you okay
oh you're sleeping hey Sandy did you
come to help me yes SpongeBob what is
this machine how the [__] should I know
we were putting in it and I think it's
gonna split me in half Sandy Cheeks I'm
coming to clap those cheeks
he's coming Sammy you have to hide in
the closet
SpongeBob get ready to die Squidward no
please I will do anything if you let me
go
um squids don't have dicks get [__]
SpongeBob
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
man that's taking a while to split them
in F I think he's gone
um okay uh
did you leave any uh really important
tools line whoa hey
[Music]
okay anyway like I was saying did you
leave any really important tools lying
around like a chainsaw or uh ah this'll
do this will beat the crap out I never
on
walking in get in get in why are you
done
horrifying it's that dead of night all
over again I can only assume that he's
eventually gonna go into one of those
side rooms right you better do it God
damn it do it oh
God you'll never find me
uh
hello okay ah ah you were waiting for me
uh that's a problem I see ah ow uh
where's that gonna set me back to
oh no
all the way to
the bang
you're kidding me
how could you do this to me what
ah turns out you can't be careless
Squidward will eviscerate you and
disembow you and then play jump rope
with your entrails
let's try that again oh my god Patrick
hurry up
hurry up hurry up Patrick Patrick hurry
up Patrick Patrick figure it out it's a
corner Patrick come on we gotta make up
for lost time Patrick we got things to
do places to be you gotta stay alive
[Music]
or something like that uh take your time
take your time
[Music]
any day now now would be a good time
thank you thank
you thank you very much
okay
back in it
[Music]
not gonna mess it up this time
messing it up currently messing it up
just about to mess it up Gary no
I'll just go on by let's go right on by
yeah that's it where you going You're
Gonna keep going good good that's good
that's good right there
wait why
I don't like that just stopping
that doesn't bode well
okay
you went in there where was in there
no you just went around the corner okay
okay
wait [__] it [__] it why bucket what do
I need bucket for I don't know
what would I need a bucket for don't go
in here
[Music]
[Applause]
how do I do
what do I do
oh there we go
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you could stop screaming I need to
hear
I'll grab this bucket fill it with water
splush it on the electronics
then it'll be done
I know I'm very smart
I'm very smart SpongeBob no water I see
the hint
uh
you okay thank you Sammy you saved me
you're welcome look Sandy Squidward is
here
SpongeBob you ruined my plans again this
will be the last time it's time for me
to die
[Music]
oh
I thought it was going to be like a
final showdown thing where we were gonna
duke it out like a battle
foreign
[Music]
I don't know what the hell I just did
you know
I gotta admit
that was something special it was
different it was
so unique and beautiful in a way it had
a deep rich story period end of sentence
thank you uh there's oddly enough more
SpongeBob horror games out there they're
available in the description except for
one that was deleted for a reason that
we all remember very dearly thank you
for watching if you got more of these
let me know in the comments below thanks
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]